i had this crazy experience that  happened to me in joshua tree  it was this bright light it kind of  moved in like these weird  ways that a plane wouldn't move  my goal is to find out what really  happened  [Music]  i'm demi lovato singer activist and ufo  experiencer i'm hitting the road with my  best friend matthew and my sister dallas  say hi to night vision high night vision  to investigate the unexplained and the  unidentified let's do skywatch what is a  sky watch look up  that's a skywatch okay cool  i'm excited do you feel like you're  gonna be able to do this i don't know  [Music]  what is that oh my goodness wait this is  so crazy  what if extraterrestrials aren't  traveling light years to visit us what  if they're already here waiting for us  to reach out can you at least say hello  to demi  oh  wow i'm so excited  you